- All right, y'all. Let's close
out with something trending.
I want to be sure you don't
miss, this is what I'm liking.
(drums plays)
(audience cheers and applauds)
So you can never have
too much Christmas music
during the holidays, am I right?
I love Christmas music so
much to an annoying level,
and I'm obsessed with a pair
of brothers transitioning
from songwriters to country pop stars.
You may have heard their
debut song, "Cold Hearted,"
which dropped earlier this year.
Now they have a new one.
Performing "Christmas Everyday,"
check out Stephen and
Justin Kirk of Sunset West.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat music)
♪ Da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ You know it's the season
for falling in love ♪
♪ I got my eyes on you ♪
♪ Just like the snows
coming down from above ♪
♪ You got me falling for you ♪
♪ Baby, it's cold outside ♪
♪ You keep me warm tonight ♪
♪ Hot like we're in the
middle of the summer ♪
♪ Mistletoe around her ♪
♪ It's Christmas everyday ♪
♪ You know stockings ♪
♪ I ain't window shopping ♪
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ It's Christmas everyday ♪
(saxophone solo)
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Don't need a reason
to light up this fire ♪
♪ Nothing that I'd rather do ♪
♪ Candles are burning,
but I'm burning brighter ♪
♪ Long as I'm here with you ♪
♪ And when it gets cold outside ♪
♪ You keep me warm at night ♪
♪ Hot like we're in the
middle of the summer ♪
♪ Mistletoe around her ♪
♪ It's Christmas everyday ♪
♪ You know stockings ♪
♪ I ain't window shopping ♪
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ It's Christmas everyday ♪
(saxophone solo)
♪ Hot like we're in the
middle of the summer ♪
♪ Mistletoe around her ♪
♪ It's Christmas everyday ♪
♪ You know stockings ♪
♪ I ain't window shopping ♪
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ It's Christmas everyday ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- All right everybody, one more time.
Let's hear it for Sunset West.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Make sure to download their
new song "Christmas Everyday,"
and I'm liking it right now.
(dings)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Okay, so this is the moment in the hour
when I usually give our guest
a thousand dollars courtesy
of our season long partner
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show."
But we are mixing things up today, y'all.
So it's going to someone in our audience.
So right now what you're gonna wanna do
is look under your chairs.
(drum rolls)
(upbeat music)
Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
Oh my God with the hip bump.
The hip bump. (laughs)
What's your name?
What will you use the money for?
- My name is Valencia and I think I will,
I don't know. Pay some
bills that are past due.
(audience applauds)
- Oh.
I get, I get that.
Pay some bills, but also
do something fun with it.
I love your name, Valencia.
That's beautiful.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Thank you for joining us today.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- All right, thank you so much.
And also big thank you
to all our guests today,
Christina Applegate,
Gabriella Baldacchino,
Jayden and Lilliana Vasquez.
From my home to yours,
y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, well try and change it.